foreign
[Laughter]
yeah we're already talking about the
MILFs in this [ __ ] uh show oh and
also we we have had a request for
that right there the where's that
raccoon
I keep forgetting that I have it I keep
forgetting that I have it yeah I think
Danny rolling said too that there was
like a sick VW bus in this yeah it was
um actually my aunt used to have a VW
bus it wasn't green which actually would
have been really cool hers was red but
it was exactly the same year I think
you know what I mean so yeah I noticed
that too what's that what's that noise
that I don't know
yeah I can't I was trying to remember
like what the actress looked like I just
watched it we watched it last night and
then I watched it again like this
morning she could have been all that
milfy because Jenny would have
remembered her
[Laughter]
I kind of well she she must have been
just like generic prettier or something
like that like she wasn't
Jenny's got bizarre taste she likes that
little nerdy chicks with [ __ ]
pigtails and Goofy glasses and I mean
well it depends on the well that's kind
of what that's well because that's kind
of what I'm like yeah so I mean but it
depends I mean it depends on the person
yeah I kind of like personalities more
than anything okay
foreign
Smith says I'm pumped that I'm watching
live well we're glad that you made it
here today too
you know what's really weird this
episode as Danny Rowling said uh is on
the same disc as the haunting of
Summerwind which is a collect Tom's
favorite episode so we've seen it like a
million times but oh I barely remembered
this episode but then we watched it I'm
like wow this is a really good episode
like why it's one of the best ones yeah
like why why didn't this one like why
didn't I remember this one from I think
we were getting confused with Echoes
from the from the past from the past
this one's called Echoes from here well
see that's why I forgot that there was
two that had like titles dot similar so
maybe I just was just kind of like well
I mean Echoes from the past was good too
like we did a show about that but I
think this one was slightly better it's
right there was right there with Summer
Wind but like that yeah it's a different
story but
it's good it's pretty um
there's something about it's kind of
credible for me
um
the one witness who was a kid when he
saw it all a lot of the things that he
say that he says
kind of sound like
the kind of things that I would say
after seeing the [ __ ] up in Mammoth
about how he's in bed just [ __ ]
Frozen that the fifth step's coming in
and just you know and
he just said he was afraid to talk about
it and stuff and I was like yeah that's
what it's actually like you know you
don't go running to the damn newspapers
in fact they did go to the newspapers on
this their friend went to the newspapers
they didn't want their names mentioned
in it
Yeah well yeah we'll get into how that
worked out but um yeah they they
actually didn't I don't think they went
to the newspaper guy necessarily like to
get it published in the paper they went
to him because they were because most of
this happened back in the 60s so it's
not like you could just like go to the
internet and like find some Ghost
Hunters to like come and help you out
like back then you didn't really know
what to do like there weren't really
that many like uh avenues that you could
pursue
yeah Danny Rowling said this episode
kind of reminds me of Amityville one and
two yeah there was and actually like
toward the end I even said it was an
Amityville Horror moment now I will say
there's not a huge amount of outside
information about this one however uh
the woman Nancy Stallings she wrote a
book in 1997 1996 about it it is
apparently out of print uh and it was
only available in hardcover so I didn't
like I couldn't read any of it but I do
have the synopsis like at the end where
you know because I kind of wanted
because you know sometimes on Amazon
like you can look inside the books you
can like read parts of it and stuff but
this was too old like to have any of it
Sebastian's mentioned in my old unit the
101st Airborne Division that they're in
Romania
working with all that Russian stuff
going on all I want to say about that
I know what's going on with 101st in the
Army Reddit troop the Readiness is down
[ __ ] rock bottom they better pray
they don't get into a fight because
those Russians are ready to go they
would tear that ass up the 101st just
not equipped to do if I can
tanks and combined arms [ __ ] attacks
of like what's going on right now you
know it's just the 101st Airborne
Division was a good unit for beating up
on third world little Rebels and [ __ ]
like Vietnam and Afghanistan that's kind
of more what it was made for more kind
of like Patrol and law enforcement type
stuff yeah
nothing's going to happen that's just
politics they're not going to do [ __ ]
they're not ready
okay all right so anyway let's get back
to the topic at hand so are we ready to
start talking about the episode
go ahead all right well I didn't know I
didn't know if you had like some other
stuff that you needed to address or
anything like that yeah sinuses are
killing me I don't know if I'm getting
sick or or what
did that just come in or something no
okay that's just been there for a while
yeah we already watched it though yeah
you just I was waiting for you to kind
of take it back and put it in the man
cave yeah I didn't put it away all right
there's the sicario uh
um yeah we just had it over here from
when we reviewed it which is a long time
yeah
that was a long time ago
it's just you know I put stuff down and
I don't yeah but Danny you're right this
is a heavy hidden episode
which is weird and it's like I didn't
know why I didn't remember it I don't
know why I didn't remember it because
this was a good episode yeah I had seen
it a couple times this one but I'd just
forgotten all about it I think I got it
confused with the other one probably
it's as good as Summer Wind yeah if you
like Summer Wind you'd like this one it
has uh pretty credible Witnesses it's a
wild story
I kind of have my own ideas of what it
was but
I think it was Poltergeist
you know I don't think there's so much
ghost it did have a good pair of
psychologists involved in it using a
trans medium
that Austrian guy yeah yeah Holzer yeah
he's done a lot of good work but and I
can understand how he wants to use a
trans Medium as somebody who's had ndes
and out of body experiences along with
that other [ __ ] that yeah that might
work but you'd have to have somebody you
could really rely on not somebody that's
just faking it oh yeah I went into the
spirit world and saw it yeah I fixed
communism too like oh Reverend Moon
going into the [ __ ] spirit world to
fix communism
he said just give it time it'll come
down I fixed it you know yeah so you
know you could have somebody that's
[ __ ] like that there is some weird
stuff about the case
where Hans and his girl could have
[ __ ] ripped some [ __ ] up and faked it
but we'll get into it yeah I mean we'll
talk about that because that's why I'm
always
I don't know it's like some of this
stuff is maybe slightly more credible
because it happened a long time ago so
it would have been a lot easier like
nowadays it'd be super easy to fake some
of the [ __ ] yeah back then not
impossible but more of a pain in the ass
not saying that you couldn't do it
because you could but right you know
what I mean background checks are a lot
easier now yeah but the thing about it
the research yeah I mean the thing about
it is that if somebody else found that
information if like if you found that
information then somebody else could
have found that information that's all
I'm gonna say we'll get into that later
there's no location that's right if you
know the location beforehand you can
make up a story
yeah now this um I'm not sure I entirely
now they didn't mention
um I mean these people use their real
names because I did find like some other
mentions of them
and the book that Nancy Stallings wrote
In 1996.
she if she's talking about the the real
place she said what street the house was
on it's in Baltimore by the way
um but she didn't give the house number
at least not in the synopsis
I did kind of a search because I was
curious
um but I did find one that kept popping
up but I don't know if that was the
right house or not I looked at the
picture and it's like hard to tell
obviously it's not the same as the one
that was you know in the episode but it
could be that I'm not real sure I don't
know how long the street is that they uh
that they lived on so I don't know
somebody's lived in that house for a
really really long time like I checked
it on Zillow and it's apparently like
been not it hasn't been on the market
for like a really long time so I guess
somebody owns it so and there's no other
stories about anybody living in that
particular house if that's the right one
like complaining about it being haunted
or anything so there's that
I even look looked on other sites like
Maryland tauntings like Baltimore
hauntings and stuff like that so and I
didn't really see anything come up all
that much but I'll kind of get we'll
talk about the show and then I'll do
what I usually do like find the extra
[ __ ]
the little extra bits that I found at
the end
Zach says uh Hey Y'all pretty sure I got
the first cold of the year
oh boy yeah I get some funny [ __ ] going
on too
I'm not worried about it though
yeah won't kill me
that's a famous last words
Danny rolling said Hans Holzer wasn't he
in other haunting episodes he might have
been yeah he's actually quite a
well-known uh parapsychologist I think I
read some of his books when I was a
teenager he's actually good he died a
while back I think he died in 2009 or
something he's good he's uh he was one
of those old school parapsychologists
that um
kind of like influenced like Stephen
King level stuff all Kings writings he
did the research on parapsychology from
the universities back in the day and
he's making up stories about what
parapsychologists were seeing and how it
were but he's good
um as far as I think he's better than a
lot of modern side but most of the
modern parapsychologists because uh
he was a spiritualist in a way you know
he which that's not a bad thing I had
some [ __ ] happen to me that would fall
under
the vague description of spiritualism it
didn't feel like that at the time that
felt [ __ ] paranormal
the thing is though when you're claiming
to go out of the outer body to to to fix
[ __ ] or to or or to uh or to channel
Spirits man that's very difficult to
prove that it's real difficult to prove
it but he evidently had successes in
stopping the phenomenon by doing that
the
well
you'd have to be there at all be very
subjective you'd have to see it with
your own eyes you
how are you going to prove yeah I left
my body and dealt with the ghost it's
all good now
yeah science would never accept well see
that's what I mean you can't yeah you
can't really prove it anything like that
because a lot of it's just kind of like
like you said like subjective it's
subjective I went into a dimension
there's no way to measure it I couldn't
take the camera with me right so I can't
prove it that's what I mean in a lot of
ways it's like that's why I'm really
skeptical because it's just like seems
very convenient yeah
but yeah I had an nde and a [ __ ] Obe
an out-of-body experience that was just
spontaneous kind of spontaneous it is a
reality I couldn't prove it their
Witnesses saw it happen but then they
would just say oh those Witnesses lied
that's what would happen
the witnesses saw me do it by accident
kinda
I just relaxed and fell asleep and was
looking down on myself and weird [ __ ]
happened we I did a whole show on it on
here if you guys want to hear the hear
this we've done like several shows on it
probably I think I mentioned it a couple
times on shows yeah but the thing about
it well this one and you said this one
actually ended a little bit differently
because most of these episodes they're
like oh they have a priest come in or
they have the wiccans come in or whoever
the [ __ ] like they have somebody come in
and like usually they solve the problem
yeah but this one they didn't really
solve it they just kind of left they ran
they passed the house onto a new buyer
and said [ __ ] yeah thank you good luck
bye
although like I said as far as I know
um if if that's the right house that I'm
uh looking at it doesn't really seem
like anybody else complained about it so
I don't know well they were working on
ending it too so maybe they did end it
uh it wasn't Hans trying to end it
yeah I mean they were trying to like
force the ghosts out but I think that
that old [ __ ] ghost didn't want to go
anywhere this had this had some uh some
of the spookiest scenes in this episode
too
um when I saw having seen them again I
was like oh man this is [ __ ] good
especially the one where the uh the
black dude that was there to [ __ ]
check the gas pipe and as he's watching
it and you can tell he's getting kind of
[ __ ] scared looking at the pipe and
that woman comes up behind him and she
yeah that was a that was a good jumper
right out of a really good movie you
know let's just stand up there with the
[ __ ] better than that Amityville Horror
yeah a lot of these episodes are
actually and this was like this was
season one this one was this was only
see this was season one episode three
matter of fact this is a very very early
episode but I think that's the reason
why like this show is so beloved is
because a lot of the episodes are
actually better than kind of some horror
movie cheap Jack horror movies you know
what I mean yeah
this is this is one of them Danny
Rowling said Tom you should show us the
Google Earth shot of the Mammoth
Mountain haunted house you stayed at
because it would be cool to see what it
looks like
there's I think somewhere uh uh when we
did a show about it I think we found
pictures of it nowadays yeah interior
shots it was on it was for sale but that
was a while back yeah yeah it's like a
it's a condo it's like a vacation
content yeah now the thing is is that
the interior shots that they showed
yeah excuse me man my [ __ ] nose is
coming I have the original paperwork or
no we have copies of the paperwork
didn't Lois send us the originals or the
I don't think I think she just sent me
like photos or photos of everything
so we know the exact
condo number
when you but when you go to Google Earth
it doesn't quite line up that number
doesn't quite line up with the photos
that it shows
and um there may have been there were
some concept of maybe that they had
renumbered some of those condos because
some of them had been torn down or they
built new ones
renumbered them like if a new owner took
over oh [ __ ] because
the one that I that I'm seeing one that
I remember seeing from street view not
looking down on it but from the street
because somebody went the Google truck
went through all the parking lots
the one that I'm saying no it's that one
it's that one it's not it doesn't read
the same number on it
or at least on the Google uh thing there
I don't think there was a number on the
building itself it's just now when you
when you go forward
yeah like when you're moving forward on
Google Earth it'll show you what address
location you're at it doesn't quite line
up it's like a house or two off
but like I said that could that could
have a lot of uh could just be GPS
problems and [ __ ] could be GPS problems
could be like a new uh you know property
development thing took over and they
like you said toward some down or they
built new ones and they renumbered all
the ones that were there like who knows
but it's still pretty much the same it
looks the same on the outside same color
and everything it doesn't look like an
agent at all
on the inside it had just had new
carpeting most of the furniture looked
pretty much the same fireplace in the
same place they changed
one of the hallways up on the top floor
you could get to the bathroom directly
from the bedroom you didn't have to go
to the hallway anymore they changed that
they just added the door
because that wasn't there before
other than that it looked the same
pretty much
Danny really wants to know what the
address was what's the what's was the
name of that place it was
um Chateau de Montage right no Montana
basically Montage no it wasn't was it
okay I typed it it basically means
Mountain Chateau but in French
that's right one time okay and I don't
remember the exactly what was it 3-0 I
don't remember
but I do remember we haven't written
down yeah I got it it's in the book
somewhere yeah no no we changed that no
we changed the name what was the name of
it we didn't want to get sued because
but yeah in real life it was I'm pretty
sure it was called Chateau de Montagna
or something yeah like Mountain Chateau
I think is what it meant for some reason
I thought it was Montage Montage but no
I mean it's spelled similar it's
m-o-n-t-a-i-g-n-e I think but that's
Montana yeah okay that's for something
like that it's not montage
okay you know I took French for several
years and I'm sure I'm kind of
pronouncing it wrong but I'm pretty sure
it just means Mountain chateau
[Music]
but yeah it's like a like I said the
little Bungalows are two condos
like do some people live there all the
time or is it just like just for
vacation [ __ ] I think it's just for
vacation stuff I mean yeah I know you
might have some people who live there
full time because I didn't know if it
was kind of like a timeshare type of
situation or at the time that we were
there a lot of them were owned by
companies yeah so they'd send people
like Executives up there like for
vacation and stuff
Chateau of blood
[Laughter]
uh
uh Zach said and I think he's brought
this up on another show I still think
part of what fueled the weirdness at
Mammoth is because the mountain is on
the ridge of a super volcano Caldera all
that magnetic and seismic [ __ ] can wreak
havoc maybe the thing is though is that
it just started there man we left and it
was over at Lois's house and it was at
my house it just went wherever we were
at the time as long as we were together
so I don't think it wasn't location
based other than
the [ __ ] Synergy that got built up of
going down there because it was kind of
spooky and it
man I I don't wanna look we got to do
this episode I don't want to get back
into that [ __ ] because I'll [ __ ] talk
for hours on it [ __ ] yeah yeah we've
talked about it last time yeah
all right so this we're talking about
Echoes from the grave now this is uh
they use their real names on this one
and they had their faces on it they had
a bunch of kids but only one of their
kids wasn't a kid obviously was growing
up now but only one of the kids like
Turned Up on the real [ __ ] and Hans
Holzer was on there too so I think this
was only like a couple years before he
died matter of fact so their names are
Ron and Nancy Stallings and as I said
this took place in Baltimore and I think
this story started I think they said
1965 right that's like when they first
got married
so there's like a little bit of a
prologue
uh and they say that Ron and Nancy it's
like they're gonna get married like
their wedding is like in a week or some
[ __ ] like that and Nancy apparently has
a nightmare about them like going and
like opening the door to a new house
because they've been talking about like
buying a house and stuff and they open
the door and then there's this scary old
woman like in a bonnet and she like
swings and acts at them like she's gonna
like chop their heads open or something
like that so she has this nightmare like
a week before they get married
so uh anyway so they get married and
then like about a month later they start
looking to buy a house now they both
have they don't have any kids together
yet but they both have a bunch of kids
from prior marriages so it's like a
blended family you know like Brady Bunch
kind of situation I think like the kid
even said it was like The Brady Bunch
like right after I said it because I was
like oh okay pretty much uh so they have
six kids so I don't know which ones are
are whose but it doesn't really matter
so there's six of them uh and they're so
they're looking for a big place because
you know six kids uh that isn't too
expensive so you know good luck with
that now when they find this house Nancy
said that she didn't see anything
particularly wrong with it when they
first looked at it she just thought oh
you know it's what a deal it's like
really big and it's perfect and you know
and it's in our price range and she said
that it wasn't the same house that she'd
had the nightmare about anyway so she
didn't really like think about it you
know what I mean because I think the
reason that they showed that like um
prologue was because later on she has
some dreams that turn out to be like
kind of prophetic so she was kind of
making the point that she kind of
thought this was maybe a prophetic dream
but it wasn't the same house like when
they went to look at it
so the owner of the house as it turned
out it turns out is this old woman I
don't know if the old woman had died or
if she like went to a home I don't think
they ever said uh they basically said
he's just an old woman whose son is
selling the place so I'm assuming that
the woman just got sent to a home where
she dropped dead or something so the
house was built in the 1920s now the
house had also been empty for a year and
they said it needed some minor repairs I
think in real life like which I'll get
into in a minute this house was what
they call a handyman special which means
like it's cheap and stuff but it's gonna
need like thousands of thousand dollars
worth of work but uh you know but on the
show they said it basically just needed
minor repairs like painting and [ __ ]
like that
um so after they leave like after they
buy the place and they seal the deal and
everything the son who sells in the
house looks in their window of their
sweet green VW van and says I hope
you're good Fighters
which uh Ron who was on the show too
he's like we thought that was a very
weird thing to say which like I said it
is a weird thing to say although the
first thing that he thought he's like
well maybe we like we thought maybe just
like the neighbors were [ __ ] or
we're just like he didn't say [ __ ]
but that's you know what I mean he's
like I thought we had bad neighbors and
like we'd be fighting them he didn't
think anything about ghosts like like he
probably wouldn't
so they all move in within the next
couple of months now Alan who is one of
Nancy's kids from her first marriage and
like I said the only kid who's a
grown-up to appear on the show now
although when they move in like I the
program shows like a couple of like POV
shots of ghosts like kind of peering at
people through the window like as
they're coming in or like from the
upstairs balcony and [ __ ] and it's all
like sepia toned or whatever
um Alan said specifically that when they
first moved in he said it seemed like a
normal house he's like it just seemed
normal just old and you know he's like
it was cool because it was a lot bigger
than any house they'd lived in but he
didn't think anything was like weird
about it like he didn't get any weird
feelings or anything although he did say
that the basement was creepy but like I
said basements in most houses are creepy
that's just kind of like the nature of
the Beast I guess uh so he goes down
there like to put something down there
and they're coming to some more POV
shots he did say that going down to the
basement he said it felt like something
had happened there and maybe something
else could happen there like with some
weird kind of like potentiality type of
energy in the air yeah I know exactly
what he's talking about he said he
didn't like it from the first day that's
what he said that's the same Sensations
I would get in places like that and
another one in a bad house
we felt like something happened there
and something could happen again you
just yeah that's what he said yeah
that's yeah I know exactly and because
these little comments that he said made
me
really kind of think that this dude has
actually had these experiences because
some of the people that I think are
lying don't bring up little details like
that
you're just you know I'm like yeah
that's what it feels like
yeah and he said he didn't specifically
say that because he said the house felt
normal but it's just about the basement
that he said that that he didn't like
that that he said even from the first
day he thought the basement felt weird
so then there's a scene where Nancy goes
to open the windows it looks like the
bedroom or whatever and discovers like
several other episodes of the show that
the windows have been nailed shut which
of course she finds very very weird
there's yeah there's been several
episodes where they moved into a house
in the windows or nailed shut that's
always a red flag right I think there's
only two really this one and the other
one I could have sworn there was more
than one the other one they were nailed
shut that's where the other family was
all living in one room downstairs which
episode was that have we done that one
yet what the [ __ ] is the name of that
one because I keep thinking of that one
and I can't think of like which one it
is they wanted to buy the house and so
can we see upstairs and he's like oh you
want to go upstairs and then why do you
want to go we don't go upstairs let's
have a deal and like well that one like
not just the windows but I think also
the doors were nail [ __ ] too weren't
they like upstairs or something the
largest windows were nailed shut I think
nailed them they can't find the windows
open
so it would open the windows yeah
but uh I think they had some of the
doors blocked off
yeah like it had her had like planks in
front of hers that was [ __ ] in front of
it or something yeah
because that would be really weird if
you were going to like look at a house
to buy it and there's like a whole
family like living in one room like with
mattresses and stuff like look you're
scared like looking at you like I'm like
that's a horror movie yeah scared to go
upstairs you go upstairs and like some
of the upper rooms are all blocked off
with furniture and
yeah see that kind of [ __ ] is like
creepy to me that's a great setup yeah
that's a great setup like all that kind
of stuff because it doesn't seem
because it's like there's no context to
it and it's like Sinister but you're not
entirely sure why that kind of stuff is
like really great yeah they do is being
all dodgy about why that why it was like
that right oh no reason yeah
we're just like I said that's like super
creepy so yeah windows are nailed shut
so she kind of like prized them open and
whatever now not too long after moving
in Nancy's in the kitchen and the
kitchen faucet like came on by itself
now the way she was talking it kind of
implied that they turned themselves off
and on a lot but at first they just
thought oh well it's an old house but I
mean even she had to admit to herself
she's like I don't really understand how
that could happen like whether the house
was old or not like faucets don't
generally turn themselves off and on but
she said that kind of like happened a
lot
so uh so they're all moved in like you
know a couple weeks go by or whatever
now after dinner one night this this is
like seems like a minor thing but this
kind of weirded me out because this
reminded me of like of your thing like
what happened to you
so she's in the kitchen like I guess
it's after dinner or whatever and she's
doing the dishes and Alan is in there
too but I don't think any of the other
kids because the other kids come in and
like hand her the dishes or whatnot so
she turns around for a second
and they said the whole District they
said it wasn't even a thing where it's
like oh like [ __ ] clattered or fell off
the thing they're like the whole dish
strainer that had dishes in it moved
like in like immediately like from one
side of the sink to the other side of
the sink because she turned like that
and then she went to put the dish in the
strainer and it was suddenly like on the
other side of the sink which like I said
that sounds like some [ __ ] to happen
like in your thing
so Alan saw it too and he said yeah that
freaked him the [ __ ] out and I'm like
well yeah I don't blame you because I
probably freaked me the [ __ ] out too
like I said it doesn't really sound like
that big a deal but
I mean just something just going boot
just like that that would be like really
really alarming so yeah so that happened
so uh Then Fall starts coming in now
Alan and his younger brother are in uh
the same room and Alan said that he
usually heard like really heavy
footsteps like it sounded like somebody
wearing boots in the hall outside his
room or like coming up the stairs like
pretty much all the time he said it was
like really really common to hear that
kind of uh noise
so one day Nancy is out on the porch and
she's like doing a painting or something
and Rod is doing yard work now a
neighbor drops by who looks like a real
[ __ ] busybody
she drops by and she's like oh you know
welcome to the neighborhood yada yada
she says oh man the old lady that used
to live here was crazy she asked her son
to nail all the windows shut because she
thought somebody was coming in and
moving all her [ __ ] around
yeah so yeah so Nancy's like huh isn't
that something okay because we just had
this [ __ ] dish thing like move around
and like I said at this point nothing
really really scary stuff other than the
dish thing which freaked him out but
it's like other than the faucets turning
off and on but yeah so apparently that
lady from before like thought somebody
was breaking in the house and coming in
like moving stuff and like taking stuff
and so asked her son to nail the Windows
shut
so then like weeks go by without
anything really happening but then
Nancy's Cousin Bill who's a lawyer he
comes to visit and like see the house
so Ron is going to go give him a tour
but Bill they said he walked halfway up
the stairs should he got a really weird
look on his face and then he's like oh
um I just remembered like I have some
[ __ ] to do I have to go to court you
know what I mean because like I said
he's a lawyer and then he nope the [ __ ]
out the house he wouldn't go upstairs
yeah he wouldn't go upstairs he's just
like yeah I just remembered something I
have to do but it was like that kind of
situation uh he later told them he's
like I got this I walked halfway up the
stairs like this horrible horrible
feeling of dread like all the way up the
steps and he just didn't want to go up
there anymore so there's that
then one night in October Nancy and Ron
are in bed like Nancy's kind of still
awake and looks like Ron's asleep then
Nancy starts feeling like somebody's
watching her and she tells Ron that she
thinks she hears something I couldn't
quite tell what it was like on the um on
the video because I can't hear that good
and they didn't have I had the um what
do you call them the closed captioning
on but it didn't say anything so I don't
really know so then she sees an
apparition and apparently this is at
least that's what the show showed I
don't look no she don't really specify
but The Apparition she saw looked like
the same old woman that she saw in her
dream that looked like they were gonna
like look like she was gonna bury ax in
their face
um so I'm assuming that it was like the
same woman that she saw now I kind of
like this episode too because Ron
immediately wakes up and he sees it too
so it's not like a thing where she's
like I just saw a [ __ ] ghost and he's
like you're crazy go back to sleep he's
like holy [ __ ] you know what I mean like
he saw it too so I thought that was kind
of cool yeah the way it showed it it's
just like this woman in a bonnet coming
towards him laughing and then she's just
kind of dissipates
look pretty good it did yeah it was like
pretty nice Focus yeah she it was almost
kind of like she coalesced yeah like out
of the fog kind of
she looked like it she looked like a
real battle ax man yeah with her [ __ ]
body Daddy's saying the one we're
talking about was called uh what now
the dark side I think uh we did that we
did that one though like a long time ago
I think I think he's saying that's the
one where they were all living in one
room yeah okay so we are when they first
so we did do that episode I think like a
long time ago I'm pretty sure we did
that Ben says I just remembered I needed
to visit Canada right it's like it was
like that kind of situation he just like
walks in he's just like uh never bite us
I'll go but yeah so I like that they
both immediately like got on board
because they're like holy [ __ ] there's a
ghost in our house we need to do
something about that
so Ron has an uncle I think he said his
name was Jerry
um but I couldn't quite hear it and
Jerry is a problem I'm just gonna call
him Jerry uh he is a priest
so Ron goes to the church and says hey
can you come over and bless the house
because all kind of like weird ghosty
[ __ ] is happening in there now he said
he's pretty sure that his uncle didn't
believe him
now Ron says he never believed in the
afterlife before either so he wasn't
really sure what to do about all of this
so that was like all he could think of
was like go ask his uncle the priest to
do something so Jerry is just kind of
like
um well I can't come out there for two
weeks and it's like I'm watching the
episode and I'm just like you're priest
what the [ __ ] else have you got to do
nothing that's what get your ass over
there
I got children to talk to I guess it's
like I can't really think of a single
other thing that he that he could that
he could be doing so yeah
um so Ron's like dude I can't wait that
long so the priest says okay we'll all
come this afternoon I'm like see you
didn't have anything to do I knew you
didn't
what a butthole so yeah it's I don't
know I don't know the guy I'm just
saying I just thought that was really
funny like oh he has two weeks of priest
stuff to do I'm like what the [ __ ] could
that possibly be uh okay so anyway so he
comes to the house and he does mass and
all that
so Alan's like well we kind of hope that
the priest coming over and doing the
whole they said he did a whole Catholic
mass in there it was like it was a whole
thing
and he's like well we hope that that fix
things uh you know and everyone's kind
of like
hoping that everything's work gonna work
out
now Nancy said that night everything
seemed quiet at first and they're like
oh good like maybe it was actually
effective but then
but then there's a pause and then uh
Nancy said and then it started with a
Vengeance that's what she said
now Nancy said they heard what she
called a Ruckus out on the porch
and she said that there was a tricycle
out there and it was just going back and
forth on the porch like by itself right
they showed other things moving like
little yeah the show also had a bunch of
other [ __ ] flying around too like you
know balls of toys and stuff like that
like you like hitting the house and
stuff she didn't say that she did
specify that the tricycle was going back
and forth by itself and she did say she
heard a ruckus yeah but I don't know
like how but I'm sure they dramatized it
for the show oh sure I'd like to see
what it really looked like right was it
was it just a a tricycle blowing in the
wind and going a few few inches forward
and a few inches back it made it look
like it was going forward like nine feet
and then it went back up like nine feet
yeah I mean it might have just been like
just a little bit Yeah like that you
never can't tell yeah it might have been
like totally not impressive yeah to me
it would be creepier I don't know why
like it would almost be creepier if it
was just the tricycle like going like
that like far yeah like what because
when you have like all that [ __ ] flying
around it just becomes either you know
kind of sensory overload or it's just
like over the top I'm just like man just
don't dial back a little bit subtlety
subtleties they took that um scene from
Poltergeist when they opened the door
and all the [ __ ] was flying around yeah
like little records and yeah all that
kind of stuff yeah that's what they're
doing which to me and I love Poltergeist
but I thought that was a little much
right I thought that was a little much
because it's always scarier dial in the
back is always like a little bit scarier
I think I think
um let's see Sarah says I think it's an
episode of a haunting about a Russian or
German house Spirit or something like
that and it haunts this girl and sits on
her chest or something anyone know what
I'm talking about oh that doesn't sound
all that familiar but it might be one
that we haven't seen that many times or
like a newer one or something but we'll
look into it
so yeah so Ruckus tricycle
so Ron at this point realizes that the
priest didn't bless the porch which made
me laugh out loud for some reason
like he did the whole house and then he
was just like he forgot to do the priest
of the ghosts like it's just [ __ ]
everything up on the on the porch so I
thought that was kind of funny so Ron
goes out there and Nails a crucifix on
the wall out there at which point
everything just like stops immediately
which again I found very funny
so uh so they're like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
pretty much and um they leave the house
and actually drive to Ron's dad like has
a cabin which is about they said it was
about an hour outside of Baltimore
um so they go and stay there but they
said it's only like a one-room cabin
though and obviously it's like there's
the two of them and they have six
[ __ ] kids you know what I mean
um and the it's really far away from
like Ron's work and like where the kids
go to school and [ __ ] like that so
they're like well obviously we can't
stay here that long because it's like
really impractical so we don't really
have a choice we have to go back they
didn't say how long they stayed at the
cabin I imagined that they went back the
next day but they didn't really say that
so uh also Nancy is pregnant again now
so that's kid number seven they don't
really I was gonna say they didn't
mention it again but yeah they did
because she had the she had the kid
later on but nothing really happens with
the baby like they kind of forget about
the baby after a little while but she's
pregnant again at one point they did
they said they wanted to move
um you know one thing about this family
is they didn't really [ __ ] around they
were just like as soon as that stuff
started happening they're like yeah we
don't we don't like this we're gonna
they went and stayed at the cabin and
then they're like they put the house on
the market you know what I mean uh to
see if they could sell it
so they said we wanted to move we
couldn't afford it um but we did think
about putting the house on the market
then they do a scene where like Nancy's
kind of like making food and issues like
cutting up vegetables or some [ __ ] like
that
um and in the kitchen and then the
lights above her like start flashing on
and off that was just kind of like a
random thing they kind of threw in there
now Alan then he was the son said things
would go in Cycles like for he said for
a week or two like things would happen
every day but then a month or two would
go by with hardly anything happening so
they kind of came up with that too
so 1967 Nancy has a son which is her
first child like that her and Ron have
had together because like I said they
had a bunch of kids but they were each
their separate ones from previous
relationships now while she's in the
hospital she's not even in the house
she's kind of hoping she'll get some
rest while she's not in the house
anymore
but she feels a presence in her hospital
room now the program actually shows a
scary old Bonnet lady creeping up on her
like kind of behind the curtain or
whatever like you can see her little
bonnity outline
um but all Nancy said was the atmosphere
in the room changed and that she felt
like somebody was in the room with her
she didn't say that she actually saw
anything
now she gets up and like pulls the bed
curtain aside like what the [ __ ] like
who's in here but nobody else is in
there
um they also show that she heard like
some weird like creepy Whispering or
some [ __ ] like that but then like a
nurse comes in and it's like what are
you doing out of bed get the [ __ ] back
in there
um and she said at this point like Nancy
realized that oh the ghost could follow
her like wherever she went to and they
don't really do a lot with that later
well I don't know I guess they kind of
do but everything everything about the
story to me points to uh not a haunting
but rspk recurrent spontaneous
psychokinesis I think it's a poltergeist
there's a lot of kids in this house a
family kind of a little bit in turmoil
um
you know just having a lot of kids a lot
of energy and moving to a new place and
the place is [ __ ] spooky and creepy
and uh the rspk manifests itself
as a as a ghost or a series of
characters
with kind of a theme behind it sometimes
you know a ghost and a demon and then a
boy and a little boy and an angry man
and a [ __ ] some women you know just
it just sounds like Poltergeist Little
Dream characters
artificial ghost
made by the subconscious
yeah it could be what it seems like it
could be because it's following around
so I don't think it's I don't think it's
I don't think it's location based
although they didn't say it follow them
after they left no but it might be
burned out by then and because they
don't tend to last that long although he
did say it came in in Cycles yeah where
it would do things
regularly and then it would Peter off
that's that's human psychic activity do
you remember when we were right in
Mammoth Mountain and and the activity
kind of came back yeah and it would fuel
itself up the more things that would
happen the more things would happen it'd
kind of like get the ball rolling yeah
but then it would have a way to do
things like turn the TV on regularly and
then it wouldn't do it for a while
yeah ring the doorbell it did seem like
the more we were talking about the book
like the more the more and then like the
more that it would do it like I said
like you said it would kind of like it's
like priming the pump it's getting
easier for it to happen
and then we just kind of lost interest
in it and it faded away
but you know now that we've started
doing the series again talking about
ghosts all the time maybe it might like
actually start up here we haven't had
anything happen here have we
we've been on Trend lately
I'm surprised that like shit's not
flying all over the place with all the
crazy [ __ ] you're I don't get enough REM
sleep anymore I don't sleep very well
but
Wednesday is my last little [ __ ] dose
and then after that I'll go back to
normal because your your emotions are
all over the map so yeah so you think
that like should be like flying off the
walls yeah I'm not I'm not healthy I'm
not sleeping enough
yeah man I'm [ __ ] juicing up but I'm
just saying that
um
too tired
yeah not getting enough REM sleep
yeah man I was like sucking phone
and you know what last night I remember
how I said it's like I really hopeful
because I was exhausted and I was like
hopefully I was like waiting I said well
I can't I was I was ready to fall asleep
at 8 30 for real but I was like well I
can't follow I have to stay up until at
least 10 o'clock because otherwise I'll
be up at 2 in the morning yeah
um I fell asleep so finally it's like 10
o'clock and I'm like she skipped a bunch
of [ __ ] right there but okay well well
why that didn't have anything to do with
what I was saying okay all right but um
so I found it so I fell asleep you did
yeah yeah you did but like I said that
didn't have anything to do with what I
was talking about but um I don't know
why you always have to like inject that
in there
but um but I fell asleep at like 10 I
was watching cinemassica Monster Madness
from like a couple years back and then
to keep myself awake and then I fell
asleep at 10 and then I woke up every
hour and a half because I had to pee
yeah I woke up I fell asleep at 10 I
woke up at 11 30. I woke up at one I
woke up at 2 30 and I was like what the
[ __ ] is going on it's not like I'm
getting up like drinking a whole [ __ ]
I don't know it was I was like why the
[ __ ] do I have to keep waking up and
then finally I woke up at like 6 30 and
I'm just like [ __ ] it and I just got up
Jesus Christ I can't like [ __ ] uh
Danny Rowling said didn't Tom lose his
keys at the new house and then they
appear mysteriously oh that's right I
forgot to give him to the pookie that
was at the old house no no it didn't no
what was it it gave pookie
your motorcycle key yeah that was at the
old house it gave the key to Pookie yeah
you lost the motorcycle key how long was
it it took it it just yeah well honestly
you'll yeah didn't lose it it should
have been on the nightstand how long was
it gone
it was a while it was a while right yeah
it was a few days at least I think it
was the keys because we looked
everywhere for that [ __ ] thing wasn't
it the key that she she had yeah it was
a motorcycle key yeah I was playing with
Pookie
and she was on her back she's on my feet
yeah because she's like I'm [ __ ]
fighting like that and then I just look
up the television said went back to go
get her again and she had the key in her
and was biting it yeah I was like whoa
and I saw her out of the corner of my
eye do that
as if it fell it goes and she grabbed it
and started chewing because it's rubber
it has rubber on this side and she likes
to chew on it yeah so she's chewing on
it she's chewing the key and I'm Pookie
and she's like yeah I got it
like I gave it to her I didn't give it
to her yeah we've been looking for that
[ __ ] thing everywhere we couldn't
figure out where it went yeah because he
always kept it
on the nightstand and the only time I
think you lost it one time before but we
found it in the pocket of your pants
like you just left it in one of your
pants Pockets so we looked through like
we tore the whole closet up it's like we
looked through every single piece of
your clothing like we looked under the
furniture we looked everywhere and we
couldn't find it and it was gone for
like a week and then all of a sudden it
just appeared like in Pookie's box the
only thing that's happened here was I
was upset looking for something
and I was looked across the top I have a
books case in there
and my eyes swept across the top of the
bookcase and as I sweat as my eyes swept
across the top of those objects
something jumped off the [ __ ]
the top of the bookcase
yeah that's right and it and it jumped
up and fluttered down like a leaf and it
hit the ground and I went what was that
and I looked and it was a it was a heavy
object but it fluttered down like it was
a leaf
it uh it was a ring no ring
wasn't it that skull ring oh yeah yeah
that's right yeah scoring by the wife
gave me your other way yeah the biker
boy she gave yeah I'm doing handy oh
that's right I forgot him I think
there's a skull ring I think
but my eyes just I saw it and looked
away from it and it jumped up and
fluttered down and it was like what was
that
yeah that was weird but I don't get
upset about it anymore when it happens
I'm like no that didn't happen you know
what I mean I go oh I guess it did and I
just I don't get why I don't get it it's
weird because it's like this house is
not I mean this house is bigger than our
other house and stuff and I always have
to get up in the middle of the night
let's go to the bathroom and stuff I've
never felt creeped out of this house
ever no this house is creepy at all it's
not creepy at all we're the first owners
the original owner rented it out yeah
like a lot of people have lived here but
yeah yeah it's all recently
so it's like and this house isn't that
old I think it's only 10 years old
something like that yeah I think it's 10
years old yeah there's nothing bad's
happened here
yeah I mean even if like I said I've
never ever felt anything like creepy in
here I didn't really even feel creepy in
the old house not usually even when all
that weird [ __ ] was going on
a couple times I did
but it was very it was it was fleeting
but it was fleeting but it was always
kind of like something was happening
yeah she woke up scared somebody had
around a doorbell twice well yeah but
that wasn't the house that was because I
thought and at first I didn't think
ghost I thought is there like a [ __ ]
serial killer ringing the doorbell I
grabbed one to piss that's what I
thought I grabbed one of the pistols and
went to go check there was nobody there
I mean that's what that's why I was
scared I thought it was a human yeah I'm
like nothing good can come of somebody
ringing the doorbell at three in the
morning
yeah or for I think it was four
something then it um
it turned the television on out the
living room pretty regularly but see
that didn't scare me it was just kind of
like I'd go out and go well there it is
again and it turned on again once the
television in our room yeah
and it never turns onto the TV it turned
it would always turn on to a screensaver
yeah that was always it was always a
screensaver yeah like a pit like a
pretty picture of little trees and [ __ ]
and uh which is weird because that's not
usually what happens when you turn here
it uh opens the garage door on its own
yeah that's true um a couple times yeah
it opened the back door I woke up okay
that was super weird and it was still
locked had to deadbolt and everything
yeah the devil was sticking out and it
was wide open and wide open wind blowing
we never [ __ ] open that door we never
it was never a door and um beijers was
sitting there looking at that open door
and looking yeah she was like she's like
what the hell is this all about that's
not supposed to be open and I was under
the impression that it had only been
open for a few minutes I saw it when I
got up to go to work open it was open it
was that's why I came and woke you up
okay that's what happened I got up okay
to go to work all right yeah and it was
like okay what time did I leave for work
it was usually like 7 30ish I think it
was 7 30. or a quarter to eight or
something like that because I think I'd
be at work at 8 30. and I walked out to
go
outside I'd like to go to work and I
looked and I was like what the [ __ ] why
is that door open and then like I saw
the deadbolt sticking out and I came
back and I woke up I'm like look at the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] went out to the old
patio it was a double door you could
open it up connect the the uh the living
room it was like right across from the
front door
and uh just one of the doors was open
and the deadbolt's still engaged which
is impossible
it would you'd have to either unlock it
open it and then lock it back
or it opened and that damn deadbolt
[ __ ] went through that door trans you
know like that was so weird I've seen
inner penetration of matter because I'd
be sitting there at Mammoth or something
would [ __ ] be thrown in front of me
from a a place where it was just a wall
there and then that object came from
another room so it did it did [ __ ] like
that
that weirded me out like it didn't scare
me it just weirded me out it weirded
Beijing out too because she was just
like sitting there staring at it like if
she knew that wasn't right which I
thought was like kind of funny I'm like
yeah you're right that's not right
another one I saw so I was playing a Mad
Max video games getting all upset
and I saw what looked like wind go
through my peripheral vision and a shot
glass used a plastic shot glass
fall down and hit the bottom
shelf bam like that and then I saw the
we had those big curtains that covered
the back sliding glass door I saw those
billow out like there was a wind
it looked natural there's no wind in
there all the [ __ ] doors were shut
and I paused it
and looked at that shot glass it fell
through all I wasn't looking directly at
it I saw it at the corner of my eye go
down like a streak and hit the bottom
and go and hit on its bottom and went
and vibrated and stopped
and I looked at the angle
it either came out and went down and
then went back in or it fell through all
those damn shells shelves yeah
because it wasn't sitting on an edge or
anything it was inside the Shelf
by a good six inches
it just looked like a white streak out
of the corner of my eye like it shot
down
yeah at the bottom
and I was playing a video game and I saw
do it right out of the corner of my eye
and looked and then as I looked at it
the shot glass was sitting on its base
going
and I paused that [ __ ] and went I don't
know
and all that [ __ ] it had blown I didn't
see anything Disturbed nothing else had
moved but it was like a wind blew
through it
it was weird that is pretty weird what
you doing Polk
well remember the Sidetrack show that we
did on Friday night remember how pookie
was acting yeah at the end yeah that's
why I even said in the thing I was like
be sure to like watch till the end
because Pookie's like boring us or it's
a demon she was like climbing up on here
like looking at the camera yeah she just
kept and after the show was over like
after the stream was over I was still in
here for like another half hour or
something and she sat there in the
middle of the floor just staring at the
ceiling like the whole [ __ ] time like
she wanted to go up there and I kept
asking I'm like what the [ __ ] what is it
what is it but she wouldn't tell me she
wouldn't tell me she didn't so
if you read the book and you read
certain things over the years we're
doing the show to me this sounds like
rspk recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis
it's a psychokinetic abilities
of a subconscious mind not the conscious
mind the subconscious mind
usually of a kid
but some adults can do it but it's not
as good it's much better when you're a
kid
and you can't control it what's
controlling it is the same thing that
controls all the characters in your
dreams
is it it's under the control of like a
well think about it you're dreaming
there's characters in your dreams and
they do things unexpected they they'll
actually fight you
well who's in control of them with you
but it's a different part of you one of
the facets of your consciousness
and that's what does it
that's actually like a good analogy
that's a good way of thinking yeah yeah
and it it takes on characters
you can't think it's you if you think
it's you it'll stop
it has you had to see it as an outside
force and in a way it is
because the first time I stopped it when
I was what 14
I realized that it wasn't reading my
mind that it was a part of me that was
doing it so I tried to consciously
make it do things and it just
fell apart stopped
as soon as you take responsibility for
it's over yeah at least when you're a
kid
uh John I know what it is I can wrap it
back up but it takes week how long you
think it took weeks I don't I don't know
weeks of thinking about it
and you have to have fear
if you're not afraid of it
and it doesn't seem to work as well you
have to have negative emotions behind it
had to have a feeling of fear and dread
like it's a threat that'll help it a lot
Danny ruling said what did Hans Holzer
say was happening in the house we will
get to that in a moment John Gore said
do we ever do a review of Dreamscape we
haven't yet but I've been wanting to do
it for a while I put it in the poll a
couple times but it never wins we'll get
around to it I promise I think tonight
we're gonna do the Night Flyer though
because I did find somebody that posted
it on YouTube so hopefully they haven't
taken it down yet but we'll watch that
again to that we'll watch that again
tonight and talk about that tomorrow
okay so uh where was I so okay Nancy um
you know she has the baby she realizes
oh the ghost followed me to the hospital
or whatever but then like she goes back
home
the next day and said that she was like
pretty much a nervous wreck because she
was waiting for something horrible to
happen knowing now that the ghost could
follow her around so not long after this
Ron and Nancy are both downstairs one
day just doing regular people [ __ ] when
Alan the son apparently gets pushed down
the stairs now he wasn't hurt badly they
said he just had some bruises and stuff
but he said that it felt like someone
grabbed him from behind and in his words
heaved him down the stairs that's what
he said
uh also Alan said that at night they he
was pretty much like constantly scared
like especially if he had to use the
bathroom in the middle of the night like
you know what I mean like you're a
little kid and you're just
don't want to have to get up and go down
that dark creepy hallway one night he's
in the bathroom and he hears something
and he said the first thing he thought
was that somebody was breaking in so he
like felt like he heard something that
sounded like a person that was like
breaking into the house and he said he
felt the hair on his arms standing up
then I'm not really sure if he actually
saw this because the show showed that he
saw like a kind of like an apparition
although they didn't I don't think they
showed like the whole Apparition it was
more like he saw like somebody's feet
like on the rug like down the hall or
something I don't know if he really saw
that or not uh but he ran back to his
room and then he said that he heard
Footsteps in the hall and then his
bedroom like he jumps in the bed and
like puts the you know covers over his
head like you do
um and then but he like kind of peeked
out and he said the bedroom door like
opened by itself but there was nobody
there
uh and it stayed like that for a while
and he said he was like [ __ ] bricks
you know what I mean which you know not
surprising you would
um and then the door like closed by
itself again and then the footsteps went
back out almost like I got the
impression like something invisible was
like checking on him like somebody would
check on him but there was like nobody
there you know what I mean so kind of
stuff happening worse
okay good
so he's like really freaked out so he
tells his parents about all the stuff
that's been going on Ron said because
like I said he's you know on the show
too like talking the real guy and he
basically said I think this is exactly
what he said he said how can you fight
something that's not alive you can't
really grab it but it can push you yeah
so yeah you were afraid of that that's a
sentiment that a lot of guys on this
show like put it's like I said you can't
punch it you can't do anything they
don't know what to do about it so they
feel like super helpful yeah man me and
red were [ __ ] scared it's like how do
you fight this how do you defend
yourself from it right because it could
do anything especially if you could like
throw you down the stairs yeah you'd be
in trouble and this one does like
worship too like later on we'd never
really thought it would physically touch
us it touched Lois she just said it was
a weird snake-like feeling wood came up
out of the floor wrapped around her leg
or waist and then around her arm and she
said she felt it kind of flow off flow
off of her like a liquid snake of cold
which he said it felt like
but we weren't really afraid that it
would
touch us me and red we were afraid it
would do things Insidious like put
things up in the top of door jamb so
when you open it would fall on you that
seems more like or try to like release
gas into the house
across across the wires so when you turn
the light on it would shock you or you
know make a fire stuff like that we were
worried more about that
yeah turning on burners and throwing
something on top of the burner because
it definitely had the power to do that
it turned the burner on and it could
move things
see yeah I'd be more worried about that
kind of thing yeah
like more than but more than like overt
kind of stuff right because yeah in the
middle of the night it's like hey hey
I'm gonna like turn on the oven or let
him do some like [ __ ] like that and you
don't know what's going on yeah put a
pillow in the oven right because there's
moving pillows and [ __ ] yeah that's what
I mean burn a damn house down
that kind of chip yeah well that may not
burn a house down inside the oven
probably wouldn't work probably would
just make a lot of smoke yeah it would
probably just smoke the place out yeah I
mean yeah what would happen if you put a
pillow you have a burn in there and put
a bunch of smoke and come out I guess so
um but yeah so at this point so run an
answer getting like really frustrated
and
um they're like okay well we really
gotta sell this place but in the
meantime they want some help so like I
said this is the 1960s 1967 1968
something like that so you can't just
like go on the internet and find some
[ __ ] Ghost Hunters to come and like
Sage your [ __ ] or whatever so Ron said
that he made the mistake of telling a
guy that he worked with about the
haunting
and that guy like his co-worker said oh
I know this guy who works for the
newspaper and he probably knows like an
like a paranormal expert or something
like that maybe he can help you out
so he sets Ron up with this guy now Ron
I kind of feel like I didn't know
exactly like because it seemed like they
like Ron and Nancy were being
interviewed by the newspaper guy even
though they very clearly said please
don't use our real names and don't use
the real address and blah blah and the
newspaper guy apparently said that he
would help them find an expert so I
didn't know if they were like okay with
them printing a story about them as long
as they didn't use their real names or
if they just thought this guy was going
to help them find an expert it wasn't
really clear about that but
um in any case the newspaper guy did an
article about them and absolutely used
their real names and their real address
in the uh in the paper
so basically now they're worried that no
one's going to buy the house from them
now uh their neighbors all got pissed
off at them because uh you know the
property values are going to plummet or
whatever and then Alan said that the
neighbors like started harassing them
and like making fun of them and stuff
like that and then um anybody that was
like interested in buying the house like
they stopped getting any calls about
potential buyers and [ __ ] like that so
it was kind of a [ __ ] show
so one night uh Nancy has a dream that
she's I don't know if this was exactly
what she dreamed this was that they
showed on the show that she sees like a
blue light and smoke that like coming
under the bedroom door and she thinks
the house is on fire so in the dream she
starts like hurting the kids down the
hall like Through the flames but then
like scary old Bonnet lady is just in
the Flames like laughing evilly at them
Nancy said that she had the same dream
like several nights in a row and she
said it wasn't like an ordinary dream
more like an experience that's what she
called it yeah that tells me that what
she's talking about is lucid dreaming
which is all she's already talking about
an Altered States of consciousness
so yeah it's all part of that same
phenomenon I'm saying this is rspk
classic Poltergeist that's what I think
it is
but Nancy said she
um yeah so she said after the third time
that she had this dream
she starts telling Ron that she smells
gas in the house now Ron doesn't spell
anything and thinks everything looks
okay like he kind of does a little
perfunctory like look around but he
doesn't really see anything wrong but
Nancy is kind of like convinced I think
something's wrong so she calls the gas
company
and they said uh open all your windows
we'll send somebody out like right away
a guy shows up and goes down to the
basement and he finds a pipe that has a
really loose fitting or like a loose
connection on it that's apparently been
leaking so much gas into the house that
the whole place is essentially a bomb so
did the ghost do that or what
who knows but I don't and like I said I
don't know if that's true or not but she
said yeah the it was leaking gas into
the house and it could have blown up at
any time I don't think I don't think the
gas man did that the one that installed
it it would have checked all that yeah
you would think you would have detected
it a long time ago probably although I
wasn't there I don't know how long that
had been installed or not
yeah that's what I mean they just you
know they leave they leave out details
that like you know a poltergeist could
definitely spin a pipe and loosen it no
problem yeah and like start leaking gas
yeah so well like you said that's kind
of like the kind of [ __ ] that they would
do because they would pull some [ __ ]
like that right if it was especially
destructive although this one doesn't
seem to be especially destructive other
than maybe blowing up the house but yeah
but but then she had dreams about it
yeah but see they kind of like talk
about that later on like why that might
have been yeah like why she was having
dreams about it yeah but they can get a
lot more destructive tearing up People's
Clothing uh yeah that happens like
you're trying to set fires
pyrokinesis happening there's some of
them are a lot more destructive than
this you that usually involves a kid
that's in so much distress that they're
trying to damn call the authorities
using damn psychic abilities they're
trying to use it call the authorities by
burning the damn house down that's
really what that means at a subconscious
level
you know get me out of here they're
willing to [ __ ] damn burn the house
down that's how much they want out
I kind of feel like in those situations
it's probably a kind of thing where the
kid is like really troubled or there's
like a abuse in the house or something
like that because they're trying like
and maybe they're scared to like alert
the authorities like in a direct way
because they're blamed afraid they'll
get in trouble so they use an outside
psychic Force an alter ego to do it for
them something that I didn't do it the
ghost did it the ghost the ghost called
the fire department and they called the
cops you know I didn't do it but yeah I
always whenever I hear those cases like
that real extreme ones you covered them
in unseen hand the book that she wrote
uh man it's always going to be some kind
of abuse
yeah yeah because like you said it's a
good way of
um you know kind of just putting things
that one removed you don't want to get
in trouble for rat right because this
kid's been [ __ ] punished so much that
you know what I mean and he
he can't take blame something else has
to take the blame for him yeah that's
what it is but he's but he needs help
but he's like the only way that like
that it could happen yeah and usually
anything involving pyrokinesis fire man
that's abuse
yeah like I said There usually has to be
some pretty extreme situations it's
really weird really weird because of all
the cases that I wrote about that
involved pyrokinesis yeah 95 of them
were girls yeah
like I did read one where it was a boy
where the boy was the focus but almost
all if it's if it's fire it's almost
always a girl yeah which is interesting
and you would think well man that's got
to be harder than moving an object no
easier all you're doing is using
whatever it is some kind of an altered
state of consciousness
some people call it maybe a psychic
psychokinesis or moving things with the
mind all you do is accelerating the
motion of the molecules you accelerate
those molecules until it gets hot enough
to [ __ ] catch on fire
same thing you can do is friction
it's just that they're doing it directly
with the Mind Excel yeah it's like
you're psychically rubbing your hands
yeah basically basically and you're
moving very very small objects molecules
so easy Ben said the ghost called CPS I
mean essentially essentially I could
totally see how that would happen
usually the mild [ __ ] is family turmoil
to bring a family that's
mostly and I think it was in my case too
a family that was spreading splitting
apart you're making an outside force
that's a threat to bring everybody back
together to hold the family together
because divorces and [ __ ] were happening
Zach said wasn't there a case where uh
Flames were coming out of the outlets in
a family's house yeah I wrote about that
case I can't remember what their names
were
but yeah I wrote about a case like that
where they had like a bunch of like
flame coming out of the uh the outlets
but it was weird because it didn't like
burn anything like it I don't know it
was just like really weird but yeah that
was I read about that in my book too but
I can't remember the name of the family
so uh yeah so at this point like she's
like okay the house could have blown up
at any moment so that's a little scary
so she starts doing research like I said
60s it's not like you can just go to the
Internet so you had to go to the library
and [ __ ] like old school so she um gets
into some books by like I said they're
very quite famous like Austrian
parapsychologist Hans holster I read
some of his books when I was a teenager
as well now Nancy writes to him again
old school but it takes like a few
months before she hears anything back uh
so there's that so Nancy keeps having
nightmares she's trying to convince
herself that scary old Bonnet lady was
just actually trying to be helpful by
hey warning her about the whole fire
thing it's like hey maybe you want to
check the gas because it did like end up
helping her because she had these
nightmares and she's like oh [ __ ] maybe
I should check that out and then they're
like hey your house is going to explode
so she's like well maybe the old lady is
just trying to like help me out but then
she was kind of like but I was pretty
sure that no that I was pretty sure that
this old one was like malevolent because
it's like every like every energy that
she was getting off this Coast was like
malevolent so I guess it was just like
incidental that she had the dreams about
it like I said they get into a reason
why later on
so Hans holders Holzer shows up one day
uh with a trance medium later on like
after like I said he got the letter and
he shows up and it's been a couple
months now Holzer himself does appear on
the episode I think like I said this was
a couple years before he died maybe I
think he died in 2009 if I'm remembering
correctly
um he basically says that you need a
trance medium to make things happen he's
like otherwise you're just going to be
in there with your Geiger counters and
whatnot and like nothing's gonna happen
you need like that human element so
apparently this trance medium that he
brought they didn't give her a name or
anything but um they said that they had
worked together like for many years so I
guess like he trusted her or whatever
so the medium starts contacting the
ghosts uh hope being that they'll be
able to force them out the house
now the medium says that there are
several entities in there and uh Alan
said that they apparently like talked
through her they didn't really show that
too much on the show but that's what he
said
um she also like she's going up the
stairs and like stops at the same place
that Cousin Bill stopped and got weirded
out and like ran off or whatever and she
said that well she didn't say this but
on the show they said she felt a
mysterious Confluence of energy so take
that whatever and uh she gets led up the
stairs like she's
like she knows where she's going and she
goes into like Alan and his brother's
room
now while she's in there apparently
she's kind of standing there like all in
a trance or whatever and then she comes
out the trance and she's like I have a
name and the name is Lewis or Louis
Fontenelle
uh Ron and Nancy said they've never
heard this name before the medium then
says this guy this ghost told her that
he was waiting for supplies to come in
on the constellation which I'm assuming
is a ship into the Baltimore Harbor and
that he and his men were there to
protect the city
so Hans holder suspects that this ghost
was a Civil War era Soldier even though
as I mentioned earlier the house has
only been on the site since the 1920s
um Holzer says oh well the ghosts are
tied to the site not so much the house
and one thing that he pointed out that I
thought was kind of interesting he said
oh well the ghosts they'll if they're
kind of like trapped between you know
worlds or whatever he said they're gonna
see things not as they are currently
like not like the current house but
they're gonna see things the way they
were when they were alive you know what
I mean so they're still seeing whatever
house was there before like when they
were around
now uh so the medium says yeah Lewis is
trapped between life and death and
actually wanders the house at night
keeping watch so it's almost kind of
like he's they meant to imply I guess
that this ghost in particular was like
benevolent and he was just like watching
out for everybody so I'm assuming that
he's the one that was walking up and
down the Halls like opening the kids
doors and like checking on him and [ __ ]
like that which
creepy but you know what I mean I guess
he can't help it he can't help being
creepy he's like I'm just checking on
you I'm invisible I can't do anything
about them
so uh so the medium then to detects
another presence in Ron and Nancy's room
I think it was uh and this is apparently
old Bonnet lady old Bonnet [ __ ] as we
call her uh and medium the medium said
yeah This Woman's really really angry
she's like I got a last name and that's
kiddinger
the medium uh asks this old bat like
what her [ __ ] deal is like why is she
such an [ __ ] and the ghost apparently
says that the people in the house are
her servants and that they're being
insolent because they're not doing what
she told them to do so she's mad at them
so evidently this woman doesn't know
she's dead and is still like bossing
people around like she did when she was
alive so she sounds like a real [ __ ]
[ __ ]
this is this ghost
so later that night Hans Holzer tells
Nancy the mom that she's probably like a
low-key psychic herself and like she
didn't know it so the ghosts have been
kind of like communicating with her
through her dreams like she's getting
all this stuff like through her dreams
and everything like that without her
really being like aware of it or
conscious of it
it's like probably because you have this
kind of low-key psychic ability that
maybe these ghosts are also getting like
the energy from you like to stay here uh
so at this point too like Nancy starts
to believe that Lewis the Civil War era
ghost is protecting her family from the
ghost of the [ __ ] old bat so there's
that
so Hans and the medium start talking to
the ghosts to try to get them to cross
over but they're not super sure if it
works because like I said you know
that's very subjective all this stuff
but the house is quiet for a few days so
they're like okay well maybe that was
successful now cousin Bill the lawyer
comes back to visit the one that you
know ran out the house before
and he decides that he's going to do
some research at the hall of records in
Annapolis in Maryland uh to check up on
what the medium told them to see if they
were just full of crap or not
so apparently lots of the stuff checks
out
um there was a lieutenant Fontenelle in
the Union Army who was apparently like
around this area and he was evidently
killed in an inn that once stood on or
around where the Stallings house is now
Bill also finds some records from 1787
that have the name Eileen kittinger
which like I said is presumably the name
of the of the old bat uh there was a
house on the land prior that was built
in the 1700s so maybe that was her house
or maybe it was from before I'm not
really sure
Bill finds out something else too
evidently that every family who lived on
this land had at least one person in the
family die while they lived there even
the medium didn't tell them that
so but he went back through tax records
and all this stuff and thought it was
weird like he saw a pattern or whatever
so the Stallings family is horrified by
this information as you probably would
be and uh says we have to get the [ __ ]
out of here like as soon as possible
before one of us drops dead because
that'd be scary
so finally a couple wants to buy the
house uh and apparently they're really
jazzed about the haunting because
they're like yeah the shit's haunted
because they're like what's with the
crucifix they're like yeah it goes and
they're like awesome so you know they're
like okay well you're the buyers for us
because they they were really into it
uh so Alan says yeah we couldn't wait to
get the [ __ ] out of this house and just
kind of praying that nothing bad would
happen before they could leave
so one night not too long before moving
out Nancy is in the boys room like
putting the kids to bed and she said
that Lewis the Civil War ghost kind of
contacted her I'm guessing he like you
know psychically or whatever and said
well after you guys leave the house you
should never come back in because when
y'all leave I'm leaving too and I'm not
going to be able to protect you from the
old bet because apparently she's still
here
because she's just like [ __ ] you I'm not
leaving
goodness gracious sneezing with a
mustache boy's turn
difficulty went up like your your life
you can't even [ __ ] drink man every
time you drink it starts absorbing the
[ __ ] you gotta tilt your head back I
can't imagine like how like dudes with
these big voluminous beards like I don't
know how to do this it must just
constantly have like food in it all the
time
be careful to keep your [ __ ] I kind
of have to do this obviously I don't
have a beard but it's like um you know I
have hair going in my mouth all the time
can't even go down on a [ __ ] and
peace
I want a [ __ ]
what [ __ ] would that be that
might be you I guess it might be yeah
you know but can we tried it
if I had to get a damn bit
so you're now being [ __ ] gross you
are being gross I'm gonna class it up in
this [ __ ] I'm gonna class it up
too late now yeah you gonna class it up
I'm classing it up I don't believe that
but uh
I'll believe that one okay so on the
very last day uh they get ready to move
they're leaving but then of course Nancy
forgets something in the house very
Amityville Horror at this part I'm just
like everybody's happy you not seen any
horror movies ever you don't go back in
the house just leave you don't need it
buy another one whatever it is I don't
know what it is they didn't even say
what it is
so she's like no I forgot it's in the
bedroom I'll be right back and I'm just
like yeah they say that on all the
horror movies too and that's when you
get murdered
so she runs back in there to get the
whatever the [ __ ] it is and now the show
made it look like all hell broke loose
when she went back inside there was
chairs sliding around by themselves like
all the faucets coming on footsteps
electricity buzzing lights flashing on
and off Windows slamming up and down
doors opening and slamming clothes all
that kind of like there's a whole
[ __ ] ball of waxes going on in there
it was like a [ __ ] Pee-wee's
Playhouse all up in the [ __ ]
um but I will note that she didn't say
that she actually saw any of that so
that might have just been like a
dramatic I think they were taken I think
they were taking some artistic liberties
with that because she did absolutely
nonsense because if that [ __ ] happened
like if you're like yeah I forgot my
cell phone charger or whatever like back
in the house and I had to go back in and
get it which like I said no you don't
let's just buy another one at Walgreens
but um if and if you went back in and
like all the [ __ ] was going on in there
like you know [ __ ] chairs and windows
slamming and [ __ ] like that I think
you'd mention that I think you'd mention
it yeah I think what happened is that
she said they had to go back in a house
it was scary as [ __ ] yeah watch it's
probably that's probably all it works
but I guess they wanted like a big
finish that's what I said so they wanted
a big finish they're being cinematic
yeah so she goes inside it's like well
then she's like [ __ ] this place ah the
only time that she leaves uh but yeah
basically all she said she's like man I
was so happy when I left the house we
lived through this terrible experience
maybe we can have a normal life now and
that was like pretty much the end now uh
they didn't mention like I said what
happened to the people that moved in
after as far as I know I couldn't really
find any information on anybody that
moved in there and said anything bad
happened to them
so some stuff that I found out like uh
extraneously
there's not a lot about this case in
particular I did find an article from
The Washington Post which was dated
October 28 1989 that mentions Ron
Stallings the dad as someone who
investigates haunted houses around
Maryland as a hobby now the article
isn't about him specifically it's
actually kind of a more General article
about like the pros and cons of a house
having a reputation of being haunted
like how it affects the purchase price
the rental price like to some people you
know what I mean like because they had
like a bunch of real estate agents like
talking about oh is it easier or harder
to like sell a house that's supposedly
haunted so the article was about that so
they just kind of like mentioned him
glancingly but there was like a bunch of
other stuff in there too
there's also an old article from Bay
weekly online from 2000
about Legends in the Baltimore area like
ghost stories in the Baltimore area and
it mentions Ron and Nancy Stallings as
experts in the Paranormal so there's
that I found that mentioned as well
um I also found a book which was written
by Nancy Stallings the mom and it was
published in 1996 and the book is called
Show Me One Soul and it's about this
haunting
this is what the synopsis says when
Nancy Stallings and her family found the
large handyman special like I said so
it's probably like a dump home on
Evergreen Avenue so I'm guessing it's
really on Evergreen Avenue in Baltimore
they didn't give the number but I found
the house that I think it might be but
I'm not entirely sure uh so when they
found it it seemed perfect for them they
never suspected that the odd occurrences
that took place in the house could be
associated with The Haunting it wasn't
until her husband Ron dared God to show
him just one soul that could return from
the dead that the haunting began in full
force they didn't put that on the show
did they no but that's what she said in
the book okay
The Haunting affected every member of
the Stallings family as well as their
friends and neighbors another thing they
didn't really bring up in the show they
coped for 10 years which that's another
thing they didn't really get into it
made it seem like they didn't live there
that long because yeah they said that
they bought it in 1965 and then they
were like okay well she had a kid in
1967 and then it seemed like not too
long after that they were like yeah we
need to get the [ __ ] out of here we got
to sell it so it made it seem like the
the timeline was very truncated but
apparently they lived there for 10 years
now hold on one second what's that
the return the the tempting God thing to
show me just one spirit
that's not all that unusual
yeah see just like I said
you're you're attempting you're
attempting my phone
that still kind of can kind of fit in
with Poltergeist
if you have turmoil in the house and
there's a kid who's got the shine to him
who's already [ __ ] scared
or pissed off and he hears his dad or
his step it was his stepdad or is his
dad
yeah here's him saying that that might
freak him out enough to worry that God
would [ __ ]
make a Spirit come which that would help
it the fear would help it
and then he would manifest it rspk in
that so that's not that unusual when you
think about it that's actually an
important detail
I was able to freaked that kid out I
just think it's weird that they didn't
mention that on the show though because
that seemed like a pretty dramatic yeah
I mean that would be pretty dramatic
right like to put and I'm just thinking
of it from like a writing from like an
entertainment show standpoint kids in a
house he thinks is kind of spooky or
haunted and he hears an adult his
stepdad [ __ ] challenged God to show
us a ghost and he's like [ __ ] man [ __ ]
man he's bringing the ghosts and just
having that fear not be enough to
[ __ ] manifest it yeah
something could be there okay go ahead
Danny rolling said some men's beards
could be used as pap smears with all the
years of accumulated coochie juices
Zach also said excuse me can I borrow
your whatever the [ __ ] it is well they
didn't show what it was it looked like a
folder or something I don't know what
the hell it is I'm sure it wasn't
important and then Zach said there
actually was an episode where someone
went back to get a phone charger after
they fled and the ghost threw down and
my reaction was can you not get a new
one from the gas station for a dollar
and 99 that's what I mean it's like you
don't need it you don't need it
um yeah Zach said what was that did Tom
turn on one of the sex toys
telepathically again
that's if you want him kicking
[ __ ] that uses the phone as a
[ __ ] sex to him
I've heard of that
I heard it I don't really see how put it
on mute
it on vibrate
it's not shaped the right way though I'm
just gonna I made a lesser into that I'm
not judging uh but yeah so where was I
okay so I was reading the synopsis we
got distracted by this ex-wife
um yeah once all they could return from
the dead that's why the uh the book is
called that so they cooked for 10 years
with many ghosts that lingered on the
property some benevolent many benevolent
malevolent rather
um which like I said this show just
basically showed two ghosts one of which
was nice and one was naughty uh Show Me
One Soul includes actual psychic
photographs taken in the haunted house
as well as the transcripts of the
verification of The Haunting by
Professor Hans Holzer the New York
Institute of Technology the New York
committee for the investigation of
paranormal occurrences Show Me One Soul
is a vivid addition to the glowing
literature of the Paranormal uh so like
I said this book is only available as a
45 used hardcover though so I assume
that it's at a print uh I read the
reviews of which there were like five or
six uh some of the reviews also talked
about the book being um unorganized with
a confusing narrative timeline and Rife
with grammatical errors which yeah
that's always something that's going to
get us it's the [ __ ] ghost did that
man
uh I only actually found two shitty
images of the photos that were in the
book I think unfortunately so if you
want to see them here they are they're
really not that impressive but this is
one of them
which is apparently them and that light
right there like I guess is something or
other
and then this other one is this and
that's supposedly the soldier like what
the arrow is pointing at that's
supposedly the soldier ghost because
apparently that guy wasn't there see
it's like an arm and like a waistcoat
thingy see what I'm seeing what I'm
saying yeah but that's yeah those are
the only two that I could find and
they're kind of shitty they were like
super it was back yeah this Pac-Man had
instamatic cameras and [ __ ] well yeah
like I said this is back in the 60s I
think the 60s or the early 70s so it's
like you know to taking pictures with
potatoes back then so yeah so those were
the only two that I found and weird it
was weird because I found these photos
just on this random ass like old website
yeah and some of the photos were like
from other [ __ ] like from other cases
there was only like seven photos on
there and those were the only two from
this particular case that had their
names in it so I don't know what the
deal with that was but so I'm it had
their names on it so I'm assuming that's
from their case and I'm assuming that's
from their book I couldn't look in the
book good ghost bad ghost thing stinks
to I have them to me
one ghost would be rare enough if you
had two of them in one spot
unless you're going to go with the
portal [ __ ] argument no
more likely it's rspk it's Poltergeist
coming out of some kind of poltergeist
Focus one of those kids and it'll make
any character you want to [ __ ] spin
any kind of narrative it needed a good
ghost and a bad ghost and that's what
they got
that's what I think it is it's like good
cop bad good cop back up but dead yep
and the whole Hans guy maybe he fell for
it
he didn't approach this Poltergeist he
approached it as a haunting evidently
not a [ __ ] called [ __ ] on The
Haunting I'd gone right for the [ __ ]
rspk
sir and ma'am I am calling [ __ ] on
your eyes
[Laughter]
yeah I don't believe that this is the
undead or anything but I think what they
did
maybe they got no proof of this
they found the address of where they
were going first and they researched it
see that's why I never yeah it's like
yeah it was harder to do back then I'll
give people that like you had to be if
you were gonna be like a medium or
something like you had to be like on
your [ __ ] man you had to like go to the
[ __ ] library and it's like wait
what's the address we're going let's
pull all the tax records like nowadays
it'd be super easy you could just look
up everything you needed to know online
you could come up with all kind of crazy
[ __ ] about it's like oh my God this
house like sold for this message you
know you just go to Zillow and there's
like all kind of information about the
history I've got a feeling that they
didn't think there was going to be
anything there
so they pre-researched that location and
found this thing about all this Civil
War stuff and they said well okay
if there's nothing there we'll just tell
this [ __ ] Civil War [ __ ] angle
here this narrative and we'll write a
book about it
but maybe there was something there
maybe you know it sounds like
Poltergeist to me
but that they had already decided to go
with another narrative by the time they
got there
it could be it could be maybe by the
time they tell that story and then it
takes some [ __ ] a few days for them
to actually see phenomenon they're like
oh wait a minute hold on there's really
[ __ ] going on here well we're going to
stick with our [ __ ] Civil Wars ghost
story that's our story yeah it might
have been something like that Danny
Rowling said are the mother and father
still alive I don't know I don't know
I mean how old did they look in this
episode because this was a season one
which is what 2006 2007 something like
that yeah so I mean it's possible they
could still be alive but they're 20
years though they looked
yeah oldish
they were in their 70s I think probably
which would mean that they were almost
in their 90s now so probably not so I'd
imagine probably not statistically no
Zach says man you guys are really
cheering me up when I'm both broke and
have a cold oh that's good you put a
little heart on there
you're welcome
[Laughter]
the other thing that I found about this
and I thought this was kind of
interesting
this was just random while I was like
doing a Google search in a 2019 blog
post by a guy named Sean Paul Murphy
he was talking about his own experiences
growing up in a haunted house on a
different street on Saint Helens Avenue
in Baltimore and he actually mentioned
the Stallings haunting
he said I remember playing with kids who
lived two doors down from my grandmother
on ever Evergreen Avenue which is where
the Stallings house was
uh who said their house was haunted The
Haunting at the Stallings house became
quite famous it was investigated by the
author Hans Holzer and later even
dramatized on television my mother who
believed in ghosts seemed very skeptical
of that haunting I remember her rolling
her eyes once as she said the ghost does
their laundry
okay the ghost did more than that
according to Nancy stalling's Book Show
Me One Soul which I mentioned before one
of the ghosts behaved like the star of a
movie on Cinemax after dark
and I was like what like dirty like red
shoe Diaries must be who they're talking
about like smut ghost smut that wasn't
mentioned that wasn't mentioned again
why did they not put was there a ghost
rape going on in here was there butt
Hawking involved because
that would have made like it made it
even striptease
[Laughter]
maybe old Bonnet lady was like a was a
freak yeah
and she was like humping the dad or
something jumping on a young dick and
they didn't one they didn't want to put
that on the show because they thought it
was embarrassing
that have been really funny uh but the
guy the guy that wrote the thing he's
talking about his mom and then uh but he
said but I didn't give the haunting a
second thought I don't even remember
being too curious about it made no
impression on me at the time my mother
however believed in another haunting on
Evergreen Evergreen Avenue which is the
same street she said a house belonging
to the mother of one of her friends near
the corner of Evergreen and Hamlet was
haunted by the angry Spirit of a man who
once lived there but later committed
suicide in an apartment on Hamilton
Avenue so I thought that was kind of
interesting that somebody that grew up
there like didn't believe in that
haunting but believed in another one
that happened on the same street Danny
rolly said bonnets gone wild yeah
now I'm like picturing that like that
[ __ ] out there if you look for it you
don't want to see it well like I said
well yeah I'm not judging like everybody
has their own thing okay yeah everybody
has their own thing they got [ __ ] worth
there's porn of everything there's porn
of everything literally really every
single thing you think of as porn of it
they got [ __ ] where they take their
[ __ ] false teeth out and everything
boy dudes [ __ ] damn don't watch that
they'll have it labeled like that nope
Russians will make anything man
it's that relationship
is there like a special word for that
because I feel like they have any porn
well no I know that but I mean no I
meant is there like a word for like um
take your teeth out like taking your
teeth like like gumming like a [ __ ]
involving gum probably probably I mean
because I kind of feel like there's so
many there's so much like jargon
involved with porn like they always have
like a cool like cream pie and they have
all the names for everything so it's
like do they have like a cute name for
that I mean I imagine they would not be
cute it would not be cute but now I'm
curious probably Danny rolling said gum
job
if that's not it it should be good
because that's pretty good that's right
that's pretty good
Zac says Laura Ingalls Wilder only fans
only Six studies oh my god let's go her
and Nelly Olson like getting it on man
it's gonna be like he don't even like
search for that I'm sure well I'm sure
somebody will Laura Ingalls Wilder and
Nelly Olson like lesbian porn I'm sure
somebody's made that this would be a
Little House on the Prairie oh yeah
Little House on the Prairie they're not
old women though no no well they were
young in the two well Laura Ingalls
Wilder was a real person but like she
wrote books about like growing up like
on the frontier or whatever and then
they like made a TV show about it in the
70s yeah I didn't have the context so
yeah so that's what I'm saying I used to
watch it when I was a kid I read all the
books too somebody gave them to me when
I was little but yeah so now I'm kind of
like interested and I kind of wish I
could have found more stuff about
because this whole uh mention of Cinemax
after dark I'm like what the [ __ ] was
going on with that one ghost in the
house then it's like was it the old lady
it might not have been the old lady
but but it's funny to think that it was
the old lady there's only one old granny
that's sexy and that's [ __ ] Sally
D'Angelo you can look at Sally Deanda
and Sally Deandra looks like a wicked
old witch with huge [ __ ] implants a
big old long [ __ ] nails and she knows
she looks like a wicked witch they get
her to act like that she acts bad she's
she's funny too but but that's novelty
[ __ ] if you ask me novelty porn
well you know yeah you'd love Sally
D'Angelo she looks like a witch he's
like Annie looks like a witch I do like
witches yeah she's like a witch yeah
Zach says oh no is Sally related to
Joseph yeah the serial killer Joseph to
handle it D'Angelo I mean that's a
pretty common last name I would imagine
all right so uh are we wrapping it up
you sound like you're kind of ready to
wrap it up yeah you with your entire you
with your snot it's not not snot
you're diseased got it from you no you
didn't I'm not sick
you're just immune to it dude there's so
many diseases you're immune to that [ __ ]
you went to
I was that I don't know you were at the
biker bar yeah full of like all kind of
scumbags yeah you could have got it for
me to touch anybody that doesn't matter
they could have touched like some [ __ ]
like the bar and then you touched it you
could have got it from the dude that
called you kitty milk yeah
Big John
yeah what you got there when is that you
do that's not that's not a beard that's
a little that says little kitties
drinking out let me go get some kitty
milk
little kitty meal
maybe see maybe you got it for me I just
started laughing he started laughing
okay maybe you got it from him and he
didn't say milk he said milk milk well
yeah I got it you're kidding milk
yeah I got it I gotta pronounce it like
a bike like a southern but you got it
over that kitty milk
yes
[Laughter]
I can even face like a little kitty like
a little kitty meal get you a little
saucer you can lick it up like that but
you need milk
you should have made him get you a
saucer important some beer in it I just
[ __ ] bought a mess make it to happen
get out of here walk away he's laughing
but I just well I was just saying
because it's like immediate like you get
sick and you immediately blame me yeah
even though you were just at the biker
bar like a day or two ago that's part of
the show
he's just mad you're just mad because I
have a better immune system than you no
no no
because I get like some of the stuff and
I get like I was like I feel kind of
sniffly for like six hours and I'm like
I'm fine I'm fine I've been like that my
whole life though I have a I have a good
immune system uh black frog said Tom
needs to do voices in a cartoon yeah
you'd probably be like a good boy you
could do like a good boy you'd be a good
voice actor yeah I kind of feel like
yeah maybe you should do that it's like
you'd be like your second career nuke
do wild west voices and [ __ ] yeah yeah
Danny Rowling Said Knock on Wood Jenny
you'll Jinx yourself I don't know I've
said that enough times that
I kind of thought that too but it's like
it hasn't happened so far so I'm all
right I think I'm all right I'm just
sitting here waiting for my last round
ammunition
pass it Out Boy we gonna fight tonight
what is that gonna get ready for him
what does that have to do we're gonna
fight the Comanche oh okay there's
something that's wild west voices oh
okay Wild West voices yeah yeah yeah
yeah I totally like some [ __ ] from Josie
Wales yeah
yeah Zach said I probably caught all
kind of Cooties from the gay bar the
other day oh yeah that's where cooties
come from
generation
[Laughter]
cootie patient zero yeah I kind of feel
like the biker bar that's probably like
pretty high up in the in the in the
hierarchy too okay
manufacturing facility
stand back hold on
then Danny rolling said Bonnets and
busts
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah that's that sounds like a great
like granny porn series
Bonnie's and bust two yeah
that's like yeah I can see that I can
see that oh [ __ ] Zach wants me to do
L Ron Hubbard I do the L wrong you got
to do the lips well you see you have to
understand
paranormal paranormal
paranormal stuff goes way back millions
of years
back on Zeta reticulon 5.
there was a big Intergalactic war
between Zeta reticulum and another
people called some takuchis
the cochis were a whole clan of people
that
what did they do they they used to learn
the powers of the Mind
of course Lucas stole that called him
Jedi
but but uh I'm the original source for
all this they they channeled me all the
time now he read my books read
Battlefield Earth it'll explain all
about it
yeah so that that's uh that's how run
over
I kind of feel like I was gonna say your
lips have to come way out yeah when
you're just yeah you don't have big
enough lips really but because you kind
of had a little slope you really need
like like big liver lips yeah yeah like
to do like big grouper lips yeah to
really get the full effect maybe maybe I
could get you like some wax lips that
might help yeah
okay that's it no I'm done okay that's
it I'm done yeah all right I guess we'll
wrap it up okay so like I said
a couple of you guys recommended that we
do the Stephen King movie The Night
Flyer so I found it on YouTube so we'll
watch that tonight and we'll talk about
that tomorrow with Matt oh man I gotta
watch a movie okay
I'm sleepy okay go ahead it's all right
I'll watch it all right and now I'm just
[ __ ] sleepy [ __ ] I'll probably fall
asleep during that I'll take I'll take
care of it if it's another bad Steven uh
Stephen King a lot of people seem to
like this one actually because I could
barely keep my my eyes open during bad
Stephen King movies
depends on how bad it is though
that's okay I'll watch it I'll watch it
I can stay awake all right so uh thanks
everybody for dropping by listening to
us talk about the haunting actually next
Monday is Halloween so that's gonna be
like I said we'll do a haunting but
we'll also like do a Halloween special
kind of thing
so you know what I mean uh so thanks for
dropping by tomorrow we'll be back
talking about a movie same time same
channel so we will see you guys again
tomorrow have a good evening good night